un ami avec qui je joue au football
depuis très longtemps et qu entraîneur
dans un club à l'eau suite à ces
vacances personnelles annuel je l'invité
à sa demande un match amical de nos
petits à yvias ali mais ils assistent au
match l'a vu le niveau des enfants il a
trouvé qu'il avait qu'ils avaient un
niveau très intéressant et à la suite de
ça ils nous invitaient au tournoi de son
club pour premiers échanges entre la
martinique l'angleterre c'est important
parce que ça leur permet de découvrir
une autre culture footballistique de se
confronter à un autre niveau surtout que
lors de ce tournoi là il ya des équipes
professionnelles semi professionnel
sachant qu'un nous en martinique nous
sommes origines amateurs ça leur permet
de découvrir on va dire en quelque sorte
le niveau pour dès le plus jeune âge de
se confronter à des propos nous
connaissons pas le niveau des équipes
d'angleterre surtout chez les jeunes
comme c'est moins médiatisé que les
professionnels même s'ils n'ont pas
forcément le niveau mais ça nous fera
une expérience mais moi je pense qu'ils
ont le niveau pour
pour un tournoi de ce calibre oui nous
partons confiants